what I want to do in this video is talk
about the difference between vectors
vectors and scalars and they might sound
like very complicated ideas but we'll
see over the course of the videos that
they're actually very simple ideas so
first I'll give you a little bit of a
definition and then I'll give you a
bunch of examples and I think the
examples will make things super clear
hopefully they'll make things super
clear a vector is something that has a
magnitude a magnitude and or you could
kind of view that as a size and it has a
direction so and and it has a direction
and it has a direction a scalar only has
a magnitude or size and if that doesn't
make sense to you it will hopefully make
sense to you in a second when I show you
an example for example let's say that I
have a let's say that that's the ground
right there let me do the ground in a
more appropriate ground like color so
this is green right over here and let's
say that I pick and I have a brick here
I have a brick on the ground and I pick
up that brick and I move it and I move
it over to this place right over here so
I move the brick right over there and
then I take a ruler out and I say wow
I've moved the brick I have moved the
brick five meters I have moved the brick
five meters so my question to you is my
measurement of five meters is it a
vector or a scalar well if I just tell
you five meters you just know the size
of the movement you just know the
magnitude of the movement so if someone
were to just say five meters five meters
this is a scalar quantity scalar
quantity and when we're referring to
moving something or or how much
something has I guess changed its
position and I don't give you the
direction we're talking about distance
and I'm assuming you've heard the word
distance how far of a distance has
something traveled so this is
distance so we could say that this block
or this brick because of my picking it
up and moving it has moved a distance of
five meters but if I didn't show you
this picture here and someone just told
you that it moved a distance of five
meters you wouldn't know if it moved to
the right five meters you wouldn't know
if it move to the left five meters if it
moved up or down or in or out or you
don't know what direction it moved five
meters you just know it moved five
meters if you want to specify that so we
could say that this brick right over
here that it moved five five meters to
the five meters to the left to five
meters to the left now we have specified
a magnitude right over there so that is
a magnitude and we have specified a
direction to the left so you now
explicitly know that they went five
meters to the oh sorry it should be five
meters to the right let me change that
so five meters to the to the that's why
the direction to the right is what it
got moved FiOS started here it went five
meters to the right so once again the
magnitude is five meters and in the
direction is to the right so what I've
just described to you right here is a
vector quantity so this all of this
business right over here this is a
vector and when you talk about the
movement the change in position and you
give its direction the vector version of
distance I guess you could call it is
displacement so this right here is
displacement displacement so the correct
thing to say you would say that this
brick has been displaced five meters to
the right or it has been moved a
distance of five meters distance is a
scalar quantity I didn't tell you what
direction we moved it in displacement is
a vector quantity we told you that it is
to the right now let's explore this if
we talk about the actual well we'll talk
about the speed or velocity of something
so let's say that my let's say that my
that this five meters was traveled and
let's say that the change in time let's
say that the change in time and when I
let me just because you're probably not
familiar what that means so let's say
that the change in time right here
change in time when I moved this block
five meters let's say that it was I
don't know let's say that this the
change in time was two seconds so maybe
right when I when the block started
moving maybe on my stopwatch it said
zero and then on my stopwatch when it
stopped moving it said or when it got to
this position I should say when it left
from this position my stopwatch said
zero when it got to this position my
stopwatch said two seconds so the change
in time or the duration we're dealing
with is two seconds and this is you know
for all we know time only goes in the
positive direction so you could you know
you could assume that it's what you
could you could pick that as a vector or
scalar quantity I guess because there's
only one direction for time as far as we
know or at least in that what we're in
what we're going to deal with for the
the simple physics so what is so what's
a measure of how fast this thing moved
so how fast did this thing move so we
could say it moved five meters in two
seconds let me write this down so it
moved five meters it moved five meters
per 2 seconds per 2 seconds or we could
write this as five halves of a meter per
second or 5/2 is what 5/2 is 2.5 meters
per second meters per second meters per
second this right here is just the 5/2
let me make that clear that right there
is just the 5 divided by the 2 so my
question to you this 2.5 meters per
second tells you how how far it traveled
in a certain amount of time is this a
vector or a scalar quantity it is
telling you how fast into it but is it
giving you just a size of this of how
fast it went or is it also giving you
direct
well I don't see any direction here so
this is a scalar quantity and the scalar
quantity for how fast something is going
for how fast something is going is speed
so we could say that the speed of the
brick is 2.5 meters per second now if we
do the same calculation we say it went
to if we say it went 5 meters 5 I'll
just write em 4 meters 5 meters to the
right in 2 seconds in 2 seconds then
what do we get we get 2.5 once again 2.5
meters per second I'll just abbreviate
them as meters per second meters per
second to the right to the right so is
this a vector or scalar quantity I'm
telling you the the the magnitude of the
speed that's right here this is the
magnitude two point five meters per
second and I'm also telling you the
direction to the right so this is a
vector quantity this is a vector
quantity and when you specify both the
speed and the direction so the two point
five meters per second is a scalar and
the direction you are talking about
velocity you are talking about velocity
so easy way to think about it if you're
thinking about change in position and
you specify the direction of the change
in position you're talking about
displacement if you're not talking about
the direction you want the scalar
version you're talking about distance if
you're talking about how fast something
is going and you give the direction that
it's going in you're talking about
velocity if you don't give the direction
you are talking about speed hopefully
that that helps you a little bit in the
next video we're gonna start working
with these a little bit to start solving
some basic basic questions about how
fast something is going or how far it
might travel or how long it might take
it to get someplace